china's centered cult classic fight club
and made an alternative ending oh it's
you at the end and the story's author
absolutely loved it chuck pollanick who
wrote the original book of the david
fincher directed 1999 here called the
new ending super wonderful and that
everyone gets a happy ending in china a
little bit sucky maybe 10 cent the
chinese netflix who changed the ending
has yet to say why it was changed but
it's infuriated fight club fanatics
truck laughed at the new ending annoyed
people saying that he's used to
censorship because in the past the us
banned his books the old ending shows
buildings being blown up and the
anarchists winning this is the new
ending literally this is the new ending
trust me
everything's gonna move
genius